all right let's get this thing up and
running
[Music]
that's checkout got this framed and all
that fun stuff if I can get this stuff
to cooperate hey how's everybody doing
ah dude there we go
I just tilt that up a little bit sorry
this is gonna jiggle a little bit more
that was that how we doing there that's
solid I'll take it hey folks how goes it
this has been it's annoying
cuz I had a nice enough weekend but this
workweek not my favorite of late so ya
already would the hair today well I mean
I've been starting with it down more
often on the live streams how are you ah
I'm just trying to figure out what I'm
gonna do with my car I'm waiting to hear
what is gonna cost me to fix whatever
the heck is wrong with it and it's just
uh it's just a question of whether Wow
yeah I was gonna say it's a question of
whether it makes more sense for me to
just to just put a down payment on a
replacement car that actually does make
more sense but I can't afford that so
what I'm probably gonna have to do is
pay whatever it cost me to keep my car
running and hope that it doesn't
completely fall apart before I'm able to
save up enough for a down payment on
something else and I don't like that
plan I actually actively hate it cuz I
don't like any
plan that is the basically dependent on
nothing else going wrong it does it
feels naive but like I just I can't I
can't afford a down payment on a
replacement so that's kind of what I'm
stuck with I hate driving with a furious
passion I don't mind driving I hate the
expenses involved with owning a car
that's what I hate finally made a live
stream hello from Liverpool welcome are
you wishing the US had good public
transportation well some of the u.s.
does have good public transportation
I've lived in places with good public
transportation I lived in New York City
lived in Boston which is decent but
right now I live in Vermont
then this is a rural sparsely populated
area the me even having the expectation
of there being public transport where I
live it would be a little ridiculous to
be frank about it this is one I'm glad I
get free public transport ya know that
would be amazing
well I think you need a bike yeah
problem is I where I currently work it's
a half hour drive by car on the highway
so aside from the fact that trying to
bike it would probably take me 2 to 3
hours uh there's also the fact that you
can't ride a bike on the highway so be
illegal for me to try if you get a new
car you might not need a down payment if
you spread out the loan I did that
though was years ago I mean there are
ways around it but my worry is that if I
don't if I don't do a down payment I am
afraid that that's gonna land me with
with monthly payments that are gonna
break my back so I sort of I know what I
can handle monthly payment wise and I
kinda need to make a decent down payment
so that that doesn't kill me but what
can you do
roller-skated ha ha
um so buses aren't an option where I
live no there's no buses I mean
technically there's like there's like a
literal like local transport for like
some of the assisted living on the edge
of towns like intermittently come
downtown so but that's it like there's
nothing that goes from where I live to
where I work I mean this is kind of the
reason I don't want to have a car or
learn to drive if you can avoid having
to drive I recommend you do that Oh
Thank You Blake much appreciated what
are you eating I am eating raspberries I
have a Seventh Doctor themed mug nice ah
I live in the country what our busses
yeah yeah burns you and I'd like that's
pretty much right where I am too uh do
you work how because no I don't work out
and actually like more than a point like
this I I have lost muscle mass because
I'm on T blockers so like whatever
muscle definition I used to have like
this is doing like this is it is
significantly harder for me to pick up
stuff that used to be much easier for me
to pick up so I just moved out of my uni
and the busses were held today I mean
like in the worlds of public transport
buses actually like it was it was
usually it was a really bad part of my
my commute when I was in Boston or New
York if any part of it involved a bus
like Subway's are great like they're
terrible but they're great they're
terrible because everything's kind of
terrible but uh gonna be in California
for three weeks for acting gigs I got
whoa congratulations
his working out relies on lifting mugs
with water yeah pretty much are you
transitioning oh ok so are you
transitioning or why are you taking
testosterone blockers I've talked about
this elsewhere but I'll just since I not
everyone knows I'll just mention it real
quick
I'm not transit I'm not a trans woman so
no I'm not transitioning the way most
people mean that when they ask because
I'm not on estrogen so being on
testosterone blockers the idea is to
basically sort of set my default to
something closer to a neutral because
previously you know just my default was
male
that's just what it was so that meant
that being gender fluid if I was in a
feminine mindset it was a lot of work to
get myself feeling like I was properly
embodying my femininity by bringing my
testosterone down because I'm actually
not even on the full dose that I would
be on if I was transitioning to life as
a woman but by brain might testosterone
on sort of sets my default something
closer to the middle which makes it more
or less an equal amount of effort for me
to go feminine go masculine and not more
work to do one or the other so that's
sort of the the theory behind that I've
been on testosterone blockers for about
a year and a half a little bit more than
that now the bus's in Japan were
legendary US public transportation is a
joke well yes US public transportation
in the vast majority places is not not
anything to brag about taxis are too
expensive yeah boy I remember when I
worked in Boston cuz I worked at a bar
and the thing is Boston for his largest
city as it is it basically shuts down at
midnight like everything closes and that
included the bar think last call was was
like quarter quarter to twelve and then
kicked everybody out by 1:00 a.m. um but
at the time I was there they had just
discontinued the night our bus service
back but at the time I was working there
there was no late night bus and so that
that meant when I got a word when I got
out of work at the bar at about 2:00 or
3:00 in the morning my options were
either wait three hours for the subways
to start running again or blow half my
tips on a taxi home and that and it was
usually the latter now thank you Connor
I find it to meaning that certain
organizations are accusing Thomas the
Tank Engine of being hateful propaganda
as a childhood fan that cussed me deep
okay I've missed that it's funny
sometimes I think so I think I think
because I have some opinions on
representation and things like that I
think people expect me to be dialed in
to the controversies and I'm usually not
like I'll stumble across them I mean
people will bring them to my attention
but like half the time I see something
like that I'm like wait what's going on
now so I'm actually totally out of the
loop on that Doctor Who or Harry Potter
well I mean if you're gonna make me pick
it's gonna be Doctor Who but I do like
them both quite a bit have you seen the
Aladdin live-action movie no and my
daughter did not ask to see it this
coming weekend I'll have to go see
Secret Life of pets too cuz there's no
way that she won't want to see that but
you know I'll live through that
ah nice hair thank you are you very much
uh who would you cast as the doctor I
don't really do the fan cast thing my
brain doesn't quite work that way in
terms of envisioning who's the best
actor to play this part like I I like to
think I'm decent at assessing how good
it might work when someone is actually
casters being rumored but like actually
making the initial proposition it's
rarely my my bag um are you hyped for
Toy Story for I'm not I'm just not you
should see Rocket Man I have seen Rocket
Man listen I went to that on Friday
night went to see that it was pretty
good
I liked that it was done as a flat-out
musical where like the characters
actually burst into the ends of the
Elton John songs because structurally it
is very it is very similar to just sort
of the standard template for musical
biopics so I think doing it that way
made it a little bit different made it
more enjoyable because otherwise it
would have been it would have been very
rote and what if it would have felt like
especially in the wake of Bohemian
Rhapsody it would have felt pretty
derivative but you know by having that
distinctly different approach to it that
actually uh yeah that that helped that
boosted it it wasn't perfect there was a
10 or 15 minutes towards the tail on
that I'm like I figure you put those
there cuz it was a significant enough
event in his life that people would have
thought it was weird if you didn't
include it but like narrative Lee that
shouldn't be there um fam there's
controversies over Rocket Man being
straight washed scene again when I get
back to Rocket oh oh it was what was it
it was um was in Russia wasn't it though
the I saw the headline I didn't read the
article um but yeah I think it was like
the Russian release of the film got
massively edited to remove the
homosexual content ie the what a very
large chunk of the movie is about
because like not to belabor the point
but not really is Elton John a gay man
I'll just a very gay man just yeah
that's I mean you know it's the Russian
release and given the current Russian
climate on lgbtq+ right I'm not shocked
but you know
have you seen us I haven't but I think
it's finally um like hitting digital or
whatnot so I'm gonna see if I can get it
without like having to pay for the full
price of the movie cuz I really I really
still want to see that the rocker man
stabbed actually said were sad that the
movie was censored I love that they
didn't hide at all that actually is nice
it's nice that they weren't making
excuses for it because that that tends
to happen a fair amount of times because
that's that's the corporate line because
the studio's releasing these what still
wanna in that market even cut down I
mean this kind of what I talked about
when I talk about the Chinese market a
couple months ago so it's nice that if
not the studio involved at the very
least the people making it felt free
that they could freely express why why
this is screwed up so that was nice
they weren't expected to toe the company
like hang on Elton John is gay Mel
Brooks is Jewish I heard a David Bowie
biopic is in the works I think it has
been for a while I even before he died I
think it has been um do you still want
mr. finish to return someday and Doctor
Who yes always in yes and forever
favorite Don Bluth film um Rob mmm-hmm
it's it's really tough for me between um
secret of NIMH and all those go to
heaven I think I'm kind of I think I
lean towards all dogs go to heaven it
I'm not sure it's actually a better
movie I just like it a little bit more
would you rather see Batman movie having
Robin or Nightwing in it um I mean I
think it's it's uh it's a it's time to
try and have Nightwing Robin because the
movies have been avoiding it ever since
Batman and Robin which was over 20 years
ago
now so I think we're overdue to take
another crack at it oh that reminds me
so first of all it's funny to me that
the that the robber baton s'en video
that I put out is doing as well as it
did because like I said like everyone's
picked over this when it was back at a
rumor and so I didn't expect much of the
video and yet it's like my best
performing thing in about two weeks so
like I obviously don't know anything but
there was a surprising number of
comments that are like oh no I don't see
you miss Batman I see him as Nightwing
Robin or Batman Beyond Terry McGinnis
and I have to wonder how much of that is
because they think that he's younger
than he is cuz Robert Pattinson actually
older now than Christian Bale was when
he made Batman Begins III and so I
wonder about that slightly more partial
to all dogs go to heaven only because
it's set in New Orleans and it's hardly
seen in animation
FairPoint would you like to see
Frobisher come to the main series or
even make a one-off appearance in the
main show I I loved Frobisher to death I
think he's too ridiculous for a man that
was you know where they need to bring
him back they need to have them in in a
short in an hour Red Nose Day special
Doctor Who short make him official make
him canon your shirt is giving me wicked
vibes yeah this is my Green Mountain
cabaret shirt stay just love how quick
the missing Doctor Who is coming out
after the macro terror yeah they're
they're getting really good about
getting stuff out there to fill in the
gaps I've vowed to find every one of
your videos watching them like it sleep
can wait oh dear god man I've almost got
a thousand videos up on this torrent
site great not all of them are as long
as they tend to be now like nowadays
they run
about 12 to 18 minutes on average you
come back to the other ones in there you
know they're under five but like god I
appreciate it
don't get me wrong I'm not gonna
dissuade you but Godspeed
seriously in any case Pattinson is a
little younger to be Batman a year one I
mean we don't know exactly what the
timeline is on this yet I mean for how
many um for how many villains are
rumored and it is rumor at this point
let me be empathetic about that
for how many villains are rumored to be
in this new Batman film that they're
working on I would expect he would have
had to have been Batman for a few years
already because they're looking to kind
of they're not it none nothing is
indicating that they're covering
Batman's origin they want to jump into a
story so even if they're setting it
before I mean like I don't even know if
it's supposed to be in continuity with
the rest of the DC movies anymore I
don't think anybody knows at this point
three words for you good omen his review
I've started watching it for crying out
loud
it just came out Friday I spent the
weekend with my partner I'm sorry that I
haven't binge true it I started watching
it yesterday
all right I'm halfway through it I'll be
done with it soon reviews on Friday
they're good good I've seen the Batman
vs. hideous mutant ninja turtles movie I
have not I'm behind several on DC
Animated related stuff cuz the the the
Justice League fatal five thing also
came out I haven't seen that yet either
dark oh god that's right Dark Phoenix
comes out in a few days
oh boy that Dark Phoenix is uh
that's gonna be special kind of pain
do you think Star Trek The Next
Generation would work as Big Finish
audio dramas yeah easily binging shows
is against my religion let it slow coke
dudes like I'm it takes this pressure
gonna show for me to properly binge
through it like i binge through the
entire second season of Shira in one
night to be fair was only about three
and a half hours to watch the entire
thing but I like about three hours is
pretty much my limit in one sitting so
if it's a half-hour show like maybe six
episodes if it's an hour show about
three that's kind of my lemon that's
where I'm like I need to start doing
something else
the Batman TMNT is really good and I see
a a Mikey behind you there oh yeah oh
yeah I forgot I added him up there on
the shelf you said you wouldn't want to
live in the culture because it's to
utopia and would you want to live in the
Federation of Planets ah it's hard for
me to say because and while I do
consider myself to be a Star Trek fan
I've never gotten into the extra
material so I don't know I have a good
sense of what life on an exploratory
vessel is like ie the Enterprise Voyager
etc but like day-to-day living for
someone who isn't in Starfleet I
honestly don't really know what that's
like so I feel like I can't make a call
on that I'm about halfway through player
of games by the way so that's chugging
along with the third season of The
Handmaid's Tale coming have you seen it
I have not I fear I would be too
depressed by it plus I don't have Hulu
who's your least favorite superhero from
either Marvel or DC
I don't know Guy Gardner I mean I don't
I don't know I like it's hard for me to
say because if I don't like a superhero
I just avoid them and so if I'm not in
then if I'm not being subjected to them
I can't get riled up like oh I really
don't like that was like cuz if they're
not jiving I just avoid them so you know
I kind of a joke Guy Gardner but even
that I can't really stand behind it
anyone want to see Pattinson as
first-time parent Batman with a little
Dick Grayson um honestly I kind of like
to I prefer just to have them jump in on
an established Batman Robin dynamic just
because I just think it would be I just
think them try I fear there's a lot more
stumbling blocks for them trying to
establish that from the ground up as
opposed to just kind of having it
already be a thing
did you see the teaser for the Picard TV
series I did it's a teaser boom have you
seen the HBO series true noble no cuz I
dropped HBO's Game of Thrones ends I am
a cliche thoughts on the Orval I really
need to get back to watching it because
I said I'm still only slightly into the
first season but again it is the
constant enemy that I keep bumping up
against and that is time there is never
enough of it Big Finish have a trek
range I think is based on a comic series
huh is it with any surviving cast or is
it like completely original set and
trick universe kind of deal
what billion what billion hmm what
villain do you see as overrated without
deserving of the attention Green Goblin
is severely overrated in the pantheon of
spider-man villains like he's not very
interesting he did one seminal thing
which was
his participation in the death of Gwen
Stacy but other than that I don't I
never think of him as Spidey's Nemesis
Doc Ock is so I feel like Green Goblin
is severely overrated
that's not to say that he's bad he's
fine his Gergely an unlikable
protagonist um this is a question about
the player games I okay I'm not gonna
answer ton of questions about it because
you gotta wait for the review to come
out what I will say is if the story had
stayed set in the culture he might have
been because then I would have been
asked to sympathize with somebody who's
basically living a very cushy life and
is kind of a entitled prick about it but
because they moved him out of his
element that makes him more sympathetic
so that helps and that kind of helps
soften him because it creates an
underdog scenario for somebody who on
his home turf very much not an underdog
what would you like to see in phase four
of the MCU Kamala Kahn that is number
one priority as far as I am concerned I
think it's because of nostalgia and the
first spider-man movie in 2002 I think
that's part of it but I remember like
even before the movie came out like what
spider-man fans like yeah it couldn't be
anybody but the Green Goblin I was like
really because you're wrong do you play
any video games nothing recent I
actually started playing dragon crown
again which I haven't touched in years
but now I'm working through with with
the elf I'd played it through with the
Amazon previously it's rumored that the
next animated spider-verse movie will
have an all female protagonist do you
think he can go wrong well I mean like
last I heard the I mean because there's
supposed to be a proper sequel to
spider-verse
but like I'd heard that what was on the
fast track was the one was with Gwen
Stacy
the ghost spider so and the idea of
having her additionally crossover with
say Spider Girl and Spider Woman if Sun
even has the rights to her they might
not but like with those or silk or those
variants that that makes sense to me I
don't I don't think there's any inherent
pitfalls in that that didn't already
exist in into the spider verse so if
they couldn't navigate into the spider
verse and make not only a good movie but
one of the best movies of that year and
the best spider-man movie and one of the
best superhero movies ever made
then I'm not too worried about them
juggling more than one woman
oh dear it's 12:30 a.m. and I have to
fly from London to New York City
tomorrow and I just know I'll be
exhausted meg you don't get to blame me
if you were cranky on the plane I'm just
saying who's your favorite Batman
villain um I mean I know the Joker is
the cliche answer but it kind of is I
like not always there are takes on the
Joker that I don't like um but I I get
excited at the Joker's involvement and
stuff I can't help it and I know that's
the cliche answer and I should have like
a deeper cut to show off you know my my
big geek energy but like I oh I like the
Joker what can I say I don't want to
bother you about when is the next Doctor
Who video dropping tomorrow Doctor Who
videos are always Wednesday and Sunday
Wednesday's the overdue Doctor Who
reviews because I'm still doing the
rewatch and then sunday is whatever I
I'm doing that week so tomorrow which
Joker takes do you not like I didn't
love um new 52 Joker and I haven't been
following it but the whole thing would
like the three Joker timeline I didn't
like I have no interest and Brian
Azzarello did his standalone Joker thing
which I didn't care for so like there's
things like that that don't quite work
for me BR and be right back time to get
the laundry oh that's always fun isn't
it favorite films score her
um I mean all time is Braveheart and
I've got a video from a few months back
I think was last year um for my favorite
film scores of all time so I've got a
list those raspberries look good they
are I feel like the Joker is a bit
hit-or-miss he can be I think it has a
lot to do with whether or not the
writers are trying to reinvent the wheel
with him I think the Joker works best
when they just throw him in to be a wild
card thing like I love the way he
completely throws off the things like
hush or no-man's land because nobody can
predict what the heck he's gonna do
but when writers like make it a mission
to tackle the Joker they tend to make
they tend to just try and really
reinvent the wheel and you don't have to
was there anyone that liked anything
about the new 52 new 52 Batgirl was
pretty good now having said that taking
Barbara Gordon out of the wheelchair I
still disagree with but if they were
going to do that which they did then
that story that they did for for new 52
was actually quite good at least for the
several volumes that I read maybe it
went off the rails later I don't know
how are you getting on with altered
carbon uh four episodes in on that I'm
plugging away at that as well um I'm I'm
getting there I'm working I'm plugging
out this stuff and like so much editing
this this was Cowboy Bebop videos gonna
break me like it's driving me crazy
Joker was utilized perfectly in the mask
of the phantasm that's a good yes that's
a good example we're like it's not about
him but his presence throws everything
off
like it like in a fun way not like you
should be here but like oh god this
psycho showed up crap that's how I like
him best doctor who experienced has shut
down yeah I heard about that I
discovered the Lion King score on
Spotify and it's amazing it's the Legacy
Collection now Cara if you haven't
listened to the score from the Broadway
show you should because there's a couple
of songs and that that are that were
done specifically footwell sort of
specifically for a lot of them were
based off tracks done for an album
called the rhythm of the pride lands
which is not music that actually
appeared in the movie but was done by
the same people and inspired by it
specifically there is a track called
Shadowlands
from the theatrical version of Lion King
which is gorgeous it's great and if you
haven't heard that you need to uh ever
watch Blake 7 nope I did hear about Paul
Darrow though so any ones who are fans
heart goes out to you doesn't Alan Moore
not like The Killing Joke I don't think
he dislikes it um I don't how backtrack
from what I know of Alan Moore's
comments he doesn't think it's bad he
just doesn't think it's some of his
better work he doesn't think too highly
of it he kind of looks something goes
yeah I did that but he doesn't like
disparage it but then again Alan Moore
is also one of those artists who has a
tendency to think anything he wrote more
than five years ago was crap so you know
take it with a grain of salt are you
waiting for a sequel to Shazam because
I'm waiting for I still haven't seen
Shazam yeah
Helen Moore doesn't like any adaptations
of anything step well yes Alan Moore has
been very clear that like his name
doesn't show up on stuff that's adapted
from his work cuz he doesn't want it to
he doesn't want oil teas he wants
nothing to do with it pizza is my
favorite type of pizza solid choice
you should do another plea for patreon
it's been falling for a while I mean it
has been and I'm trying to but see
here's the thing
he and here's why I don't plan to
currently do that the part of the reason
the support level on the patreon has
been dropping is that the for a month or
two the Commission tier which is one of
the more expensive tiers was full there
are five slots at that tier and they
were all full and I'm bow now around
about half of those people once they're
commissioned once they got in to get
their Commission review drop back down
to a lower tier which is fine I kind of
expected them to
but those tiers haven't been refilled so
that's the first thing the other thing
is a big part of why I don't want to put
a big plea out to support the patreon
again because I kind of did at the start
of the year and it did boost things but
the thing is my subscriber numbers have
been plateaued and they've been kind of
stagnant so the reason I don't want to
put out another plea for support on the
patreon if I don't unless I feel that I
really need to is that I basically be
asking more out of the audience I
already have um I feel like I got away
with it when I did it at the start of
the year because I'd had a pretty
substantial subscriber gain you know in
that last quarter of last year basically
what new doctor who was going on so like
there was a whole bunch of new people
for me to make that pitch to but now
because I haven't gained a lot more
since then I feel like I'm just I just
be squeezing money out of the audience I
already have and I don't want to do that
I'm not the video game industry there's
a lot of fun usernames in this chat yeah
there are some fun ones in there
my man I'll have to unsubscribe I'm
baffled sorry I I mean I suppose some
folks find me baffling you support me
here I'll shoot that Dalek happy Pride
Month
yes Thank You Caine thanks very much I
honestly I tend to forget that June is
Pride Month because Vermont pride is in
September for reason that kind of makes
sense but it's also kind of dumb so
better to be baffling than boring I will
take it happy pride any extra topic
videos I don't know it's it's a bi it's
a matter of editing so like I've got two
lgbtq+ topic videos in the can um but
one of them is gonna be a real pain in
my butt too actually both of them are
proving to be a pain in my butt to edit
one of them significantly more than the
other plus I've kind of already got the
month laid out so I did have the idea of
doing more than one lgbtq+ video this
month since it is Pride Month in most
places I just don't know if I'm gonna be
able to pull it together and end up with
a product that I'm gonna be happy with
so it's it's on my mind I just don't
really see it happening or at least I'm
not I'm certainly not gonna promise it
happy Pride you magnificent bastard Oh
John you bugger uh would you like to see
a live-action TMNT with the puppet
turtles again well yeah I haven't really
been blown away by the CGI turtles thus
far I would like them to go practical
again make me won't make me want pizza
chat I did love the pic you put out on
Twitter to me uh which pic because I put
the stuff that I put up on on the
counselling geek squares stuff that I
put up on the very wild Twitter
so I'm not even sure which one favorite
Ninja Turtle Raphael that's my dude
sorry bad bad gig here what does TMNT
mean Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles how do
you keep up with doing constant podcasts
and other stuff I can barely do one
without a hiatus I mean I'm like three
weeks behind on on updating the podcast
feeds so I'm not sure that's a that's a
great question to be throwing me right
now it's my dog's birthday her name is
pebbles happy birthday pebbles I missed
a few live screens did you get around to
twisty no everything is dropping right
now like I'm I'm working on altered
carving because I got commissioned for
that one I'm working my way through Good
Omens like I I feel really bad I want it
I will see before the summer's over I
don't know when but I will um have you
seen the terrible era of Don Bluth
movies at Orel in Central Park the
pebble and the penguin no I skipped
those so quite happy for it to love your
hair thank you I had a weird crush on
Michelangelo as a kid
I mean WTF he was a literal turtle well
yeah but he was a party dude no shame
favourite Raphael Rob Hall's Rob Paulsen
or Sean Astin um what was the name of
the guy who voiced him in the original
live-action movie because that guy did
you ever go to the doctor who
experienced in Cardiff I have never set
foot in Cardiff so that would be a new
pick up every sonic screwdriver with one
and oh no don't think so gonna end up
dropping about half of them if I try and
do that are you gonna have a Matt Smith
costume for your 11th doctor overdue who
reviews some semblance of one at least
starting out it is probably not gonna be
as accurate as my as my tenant outfit
but I've got some stuff if it makes them
feel better my first crush was basil of
Baker Street ooh
solid pick I like
rhadigan is one of the the great
underappreciated forgotten Disney
villains he's awesome needs me needs
more all right John John pase pase cool
that guy
thank you John uh I had a crush on spin
on 80s era Voltron um I never saw
Voltron so I'm gonna take your word on
that any new nerd les stories um I'm
gonna be reviving my 13th doctor number
in a little less than two weeks other
than that no I I'm actually gonna have
way fewer performance opportunities for
burlesque this year for no reason other
than the calendar decided to screw with
me just because up for the past year a
couple years actually things have lined
up very well where the majority of
performance opportunities especially
with the Cabaret have been on weekends
that aren't the weekends I have my
daughter
well that's falling out of sync and a
very hybrid like more than 50% of stuff
that I that would be my chance to get to
perform I'm in various you know
burlesque shows are fall
weekends that I'm not free I've got my
kid so I'm gonna have way less
performance opportunities this year then
I've usually had which yeah not not uh
this hasn't been my best year so far on
a number of fronts heard Chernobyl is a
very good series have you seen it I
haven't I saw Jeremy Jones's review of
it sounded good a burlesque Batman show
would be funny oh that beam I guarantee
you that's happened at some point that
would be really easy to throw together
I've got a poison ivy number could be in
it I had a crush on Iron Heart from
Silverhawks and chitara from Thundercats
Oh
chitara legit oh that one's truly
legitimate huh I'm right there with you
have you seen wonder I haven't I mean
it's just not my kind of movie I've
heard enough decent things about it and
Liz's read the book she said that was
good
Alan Cummings is sexy AF yes yeah I
think the Batman and Robin movie already
achieved that nevermind oh that's in
reference to something I missed
I'm not gonna scroll back up through so
uh forgive me for that my first cut oh
now we're just sharing cartoon crushes I
love this it is a phenomenal poison ivy
oh sorry pheromone nominal poison ivy
number Oh JBL are you sly bugger my
first cartoon crush was total drama so
you can shame me for that that's just a
thing I did the experience and just no
look I like Total Drama I did the first
two seasons of Total Drama I would've
liked that show hmm
excuse me you guys already talked about
Rocket Man yes basically I did cover it
it's good I like it if you like Elton
John definitely go see it I had to
explain Moulin Rouge to my spouse and
had not seen it myself so
not know the plot but I'm uh Moulin
Rouge took me three times before I got
through that cuz the opening gives me a
headache
wasn't worth it
my old special interest is getting
triggered mm-hmm have you seen bright
burn I haven't that's not even playing
anywhere near me so like even if I
wanted to are you caught up on
improvised weapons haha I am in terms of
listening in terms of going back and
updating the wiki which has become my
latest pastime while listening just dis
stuff um I popped through episode 45 so
for folks who don't know um oh do you
like Big Bang Theory no I hate it um so
but for folks who don't know we've got
John van Luling in the chat who is part
of the cast of improvised weapons which
is one of my favorite podcast it is uh
it is a it's a real it's an actual play
D&D podcast they're closing in on 100
episodes now and as a way to unwind
because I've needed waste unwind lately
I've been real istening to old episodes
and then updating the podcasts wiki
because I've added like not for the
episode synopsis cuz I'm not I'm not I'm
doing other stuff um we're listening to
these episodes so I'm not sitting there
to document you know what everything
that's going on but um I I have been
updating things like notable quotes
critical fails kill counts the magic
words to activate very spells and stuff
like that so updating the improvised
weapons podcast wiki has has become a
bit of an unwinding pastime for me of
late you know more about our history
than we do I mean you say that I can't
recall it off without my head I would
have to reference the wiki
- if I was in your guys's shoes but try
and remember that
alright remind the rest of the group
next time that like it's updated -
almost halfway through the run of the
thing so if they're trying to remember
what the magic word for something is it
might be there
goodnight people go to bed
Oh Elfie I didn't even realize you were
here sleep well my friend favorite
Lindsey Ellis vid um I'm I really like
her her review thing there's two I
really like I really like the one she
did on bright cuz that movie kind of
broke her it was kind of amazing and
then the the one she did on the
live-action Beauty and the Beast with
the recurring thanks I hate it I really
I really did enjoy those she does good
work in general I haven't seen a bad
video from her like it's annoying how
good she is at this favorite Cyberman
story
ooh tomb of the Cybermen is right up
there I think it might be world enough
in time for me but like to Masai
Berman's really really good that that
might be my favorite in second doctor
story so that's that's solid cakes and
say one of my favorite reviews ever from
suspects over both normal and northern
strange magic they both broke her I've
seen those suspects does good work too
bad like there there's some people who
are really good at this and I'm trying
to get better at it that's why the
Cowboy Bebop
Edea video is such an editing nightmare
for me I'm trying to step up my game and
it hurts who is this beautiful girl who
has her number for PBS show is brilliant
it is it like a proper show on the
channel or is it just on the
on the PBS YouTube because I've seen
those I just don't know if I'm missing
out if that's all I'm getting what's
your favorite eleventh Doctor story like
I don't feel comfortable answering that
now because I have a feeling it's gonna
change once I get through the eleventh
Doctor when I do when the rewatch gets
that far right now it's probably gonna
come down if I were to guess it's gonna
come down to either the 11th hour or
Vincent and the doctor Vincent and the
doctor has been going up in my
estimation over the years but 11th hour
I has always been top of that list in
the past so we'll see
have you seen vengeance on barrows I
have I need to rewatch it cuz I didn't
like it that much so I need to give it
like a fair shake because I know it is
supposedly one of the best six doctor TV
episodes which is in and of itself kind
of a strange concept
I've seen the onwards trailer oh I did I
keep forgetting that I saw that like it
didn't leave much of an impression can I
be honest with you folks I've realized I
don't I don't like Pixar nearly as much
as everybody else does and it's taking
me a little while to figure out why so
I've had this come up like in
conversations about other stuff and yeah
I kind of figured this out in the
conversation with Liz and again I am NOT
saying the Pixar is bad
Pixar is very good at what they do but I
finally realized what my issue with them
is and this is a vibe that I'm about to
talk about and I'm about to and I'll do
a comparison so what bothers me about
Pixar films even the good ones is that
they feel like and again this is a field
of survive I don't know if this is
actually what goes on but they feel very
much like the starting point was what
are our themes and then they build a
story around the themes now that means
if you do it right everything feeds into
the thematics very well but it also to
me makes it very on the nose and even if
you do it well and like it's not
possible for the themes of something
like inside out or up or Toy Story 3 to
be any more blatant than they are like
you couldn't if you tried now if I were
to compare that with something like
Zootopia and again this is not me saying
like Zootopia is the greatest animated
film ever but to explain why I love that
one pretty much without reservations
whereas there's a fair amount of Pixar
stuff where I'm like yeah but there's a
lot of themes running through Zootopia
but I feel like that story the narrative
of it it would still largely be the same
even without the theming so the vibe I
get off something like that is we had a
story to tell with this world in these
characters and then once they had that
set up they went ooh here's the theme we
can weave through it because at the end
of the day I'm a narrative person first
story is king for me
and while themes and thematics are great
if I feel like they're driving the story
as opposed to enhancing the story I kind
of resent that a little bit and that's
the vibe I tend to get off Pixar it
feels like they came at it with a theme
and built everything around the theme
rather than came and a story and a
narrative that they wanted to tell and
figured out the best themes to integrate
into that to enhance the story its story
serving theme as opposed to theme
serving story it's it's a and it's a
preferential thing I'm not saying that
that makes Pixar bad it's just taken me
a long time to figure out why I don't
love the
as much as everybody else seems to so
there you go I don't know if that made
any sense at all but I'll have to show
you my subscriber count' when I get out
here how much you want to drop how many
people were watching 90 bed bed
plummeted by 90 as you all would he's
nothing like Pixar that much gone so the
metaphor I have for that is the theme is
meant to be a topping like frosting on a
cupcake that works I don't think I've
arrived at one of these on time welcome
I hope Oh John still in the chat because
like I I borrow that a lot and again
that's improvised weapons there's the
there's the bard character who literally
cannot enter into a new space without
going welcome and I love it so much
ah fair I don't agree but you have the
right to your own opinion
I love the polite way of people telling
you that you're wrong I don't even say
that to be cheeky like I gotta get
entertainment about that uh nice mug is
that coffee its water it's my story I'm
sticking to it
I actually did used to do my morning
coffee in this except this holds two
runs of the Keurig which you know that I
really shouldn't be drinking that much
coffee first thing in the morning so I
switch to a smaller mug but yeah that
used to be my morning coffee
[Laughter]
I thank you they're uh husky anyone else
literally just unsubscribe yeah does
anyone else love this kind of stream
where people just talk and answer
questions I hope so
that's kind of what they uh what they
are
just wait till this week's episode for a
fun welcome from Cassie and ooh you
tease John a lot of Pixar stuff has gone
downhill especially Disney Plus fodder
yeah I mean like Pixar saying they're
gonna get off the sequel thing but even
a lot of their new stuff hasn't been
great like I really can't stand brave to
be honest but Coco is solid inside out
was solid still in love them as a lot as
a lot of as much as a lot of people
favorite Doctor Who costume oh yeah I'm
partial to uh when Capaldi had the
hoodie so he always kind of had a
magician coat but series 10 he and I
think also in part of series 9 he had a
hoodie with that I kind of liked that
the contrast to that uh anyone remember
gigantic No Wow doesn't matter now
because it's not happening I I thought
that looked interesting so yeah that was
that was a bummer sitting around
biessing is the best kind of live stream
whoo I'm doing it right
apparently maybe I don't know I don't
know what I'm doing folks if you haven't
figured that out yet then welcome to the
channel overdue shirt Sherlock reviews I
mean it's just so not topical now like
unless I could come up with a point like
a through-line a theme to address them
like just going back and redoing them to
redo them I mean for me redo like I say
we do it's not like I'm I only review
series four for Sherlock but
i if they ever announced a new series
I'll go back and do the old I'll do
reviews for the old ones cuz it'll be
topical again yes that's me copping to
the degree to which whether or not I
think anyone anyone clicks on it
determines what I actually sink my time
into cuz yeah it's a factor and anyone
who claims it isn't is lying cuz if
you're on YouTube you want people to see
what you do I keep forgetting brave was
a Pixar movie it felt so generic brave
had an amazing lead character and a
really cool setting and just such a
pedestrian story I just like I couldn't
connect to it at all if you had to marry
a doctor who villain who would it be
my gut instinct is to say Missy but I'm
not sure I can stand to be manipulated
that much so let me think uh jeez no I'm
still gonna go with Missy cuz it would
suck but at least they had four chunks
of it it would be fun I think you should
live your stream Monday Tuesday Thursday
say dance Sunday ha ha yeah yes any
drunk review oh boy here's the thing
about drunk reviews they they are not
fun to hit it cuz I've done drunk once
cuz I had to drink to get through Oh God
the inhumans first two episodes so you
look at my video on that I'm pretty
toasted by the end of it but that was a
pain to edit
I am a 28 year old man and a 31 year
olds body do you get this reference uh
nope sorry would you ever go back and
drunk review movies that your friends
haven't seen yet oh yeah that's a
pointed question because years ago okay
well first of all before I tell anybody
this John have you seen that movie yet
or have you still not seen it cuz that's
gonna be the determining factor in this
and this so years ago cuz it's like he's
in the chat
John van Luling for folks who don't
listen to the podcast stream which is
the vast majority of people I know that
he was my co-host back when we when
there was go home Hollywood you're drunk
and so way back he told me he had never
seen Batman V Superman and so I proposed
a sitting down to watch it with booze
and record him seeing it for the first
time ever and me just laughing my butt
off as he did and then you know maybe
putting it up as a on the podcast feed
it's like a commentary track and editing
it down to highlights for the YouTube
channel and I never got around to it and
apparently he still hasn't watched it so
yeah probably should make that happen
and also John apparently roya hasn't
seen it yet either
so I might rope him in as well
I've seen any of being human either the
UK version or the other one I saw the
first series of being human
I'm not sure what I expected of it but
it didn't quite click for me I think the
thing was I felt like the setup lent
itself to something less serious than
how it took itself like you tell me a
show is about a ghost a vampire and a
werewolf all sharing an apartment I
guess I expected something a little
campy er a little more fun a little less
dour then the show ended up being it was
fine for what it was I just it didn't
quite click with me who date night
oh boy I'm gonna take that as a as a
confirmation were you sad when Olas left
yes that broke my heart that absolutely
broke my heart because um if oh boy this
is turning into a decent promotion for
the improvised weapons podcast so if
you're a patreon supporter of improvised
weapons then you know this in or at
least had the opportunity to hear it
back when I interviewed the cast's for a
video that I put up last year I also
brought them gifts based off their
characters so Jon's character the
Dwarven cleric who has to have an ale
with breakfast every single day he got a
tankard with with clans storm hammer on
it because that was his character and
the bard got um I I got a wooden
business cards because he's always
adding new titles to his business cards
and I got a magic rod for the wizard and
for all right note for the warlock and
for the wizard I got this little
leather-bound tome that said the magical
tome of mine cuz her entire thing is
being really possessive about the about
anything that contains knowledge but my
favorite character is the is the party's
barbarian their half work barbarian
named Olaf whose backstory was being the
tambourine player in a band and for for
her I got a tambourine that on the drum
of the tambourine it said hola
had a severed arm doing this because it
had become her thing where when they get
into combat she takes off people's arms
so when the when the player for that
character when Nicole Sisk moved and had
to drop out of the podcast and they
wrote hola SH out it like my heart oh it
hurt so much can you do drunk reviews of
live-action Disney remakes I'm not gonna
promise that I will but I will say
that's about the only way you'll get me
to watch them so do you watch Rick and
Morty I don't I don't like the
characters they um I just think don't
join spending time with those people not
exactly your theme but have you watched
any Riverdale
I haven't Liz has she hates Archie ah
ain't start in unhappy I've heard good
things about that while dr. Lou
character has the most in common with
yourself
ooh huh
that is ooh that's a really good
question I don't even know how to answer
that
I might have to ponder that one then I
need I thought I need to ship you booze
oh the circle of life must happen oh
dear I already watched class nope still
haven't but I think I'm gonna oh hey
there Meg I was trying to find the drunk
review cuz I forgot the name he gave me
a video from five years ago you look so
different tude not to mention
yeah I mean anything from this year is
gonna look better cuz I got the better
camera thanks to the patreon support
whoo plug that um bought it yeah
it's a it's a bit of a different look
you go far enough back in the feed
especially some of the videos were like
I'm scruffy and didn't shave I look at
those now and I'm like who's that guy
it looks rugged the live-action remakes
aren't that bad if you want to genuinely
insufferable live-action Disney film go
watch old dogs well no I don't want a
genuinely insufferable live-action film
that's my point
and it's not my anger at the live-action
remakes isn't that they're bad it's that
they are the epitome of pointless anyone
remember the name of that cartoon Doctor
Who episode with ten which one there was
few there was dreamland there was also
infinite quest I feel like there was
another one I can't remember now what
was the what was the name of that drunk
review by the way okay hang on ah give
me a second and I'll tell you I love
that I'm not I'm now dipping into into
my own stuff to to help somebody find a
video okay so the the video is called
Inhumans premiere reaction parenthesis
with alcoholic assistance it's from 2017
October 3rd
so that that is that video I remember
the infinite quest because they showed
it on totally Doctor Who remember that
no I don't remember totally Doctor Who
but I have seen the infinite quest
excuse me council of geeks is the
YouTube librarian um like funny and
funnily enough that's Liz's actual
occupation as being a library so I kind
of get a get a kick out of that I wish
they'd do a Doctor Who animes here's
long inside the TV series I I feel like
that month that would be oversaturation
a little bit like if they wanted to do
if they wanted to do something like that
I would say only do it if they're gonna
do it like during the summer like when
the show is an airing
but like I think part of what was a
mistake with class was having it air
literally alongside new episodes because
it immediately begs the comparison as
opposed to giving us something that you
know holds us over between the series of
the show we already love I think the
only drunk review I saw was spoonie's
take on Twilight you see okay these days
not last I knew but then again I never
really followed the guy so I've been
exactly kept tabs
I kind of was peripherally aware of kind
of a meltdown that happened in there I
say meltdown that implies like one thing
happened it was like a slow degradation
again to my understanding not an expert
if you got some free time haha if you
got some free time check out Nelvana
what no I was gonna do with Doctor Who
courtesy of the TARDIS wiki I'll try and
remember doing that you ever watch the
Sarah Jane Adventures I did the first
two series the problem is it was aimed
very clearly at a younger demographic
um which that's not actually a fault of
the show it's just I was I was too old
for it kind of didn't it didn't appeal
to my adult sensibilities because it was
aimed at kids so again not actually a
fault of the show for what it was it was
pretty good and just I never felt the
need to watch that third series or go
back and re-watch it since the last
thing I needed alcohol existen alcoholic
assistance to watch something was trial
of a Time Lord have you seen that I
haven't gotten to that one yet actually
I love your Mogwai on your shelf I've
always thought that was cool takes me
back as a kid now here's the question do
you prefer the first or second gremlins
because I am a holder of the unpopular
opinion that gremlins 2 is vastly better
what was that weird it clown thing in
Sarah Jane Adventures they really did
not need to do to do that like at all do
you think the characters from Gotham
could return a future Batman's story or
their own standalone movie I mean could
they yes well they no absolutely not I
mean the show the show didn't come to a
natural end
it was cancelled because the ratings
weren't what Fox wanted them to be it
shows done like I would like more Gotham
but that is gremlins to more creative
gremlins to more funny and creative Oh
nice I'm a good company gremlins one is
a timeless classic don't at me look
you're entitled to your opinion don't
worry about it it's been a lot it's been
so long since I saw them that I might be
wrong first but haven't watched either
in decades um four oh here's a cup for
you first or second Kristine Kochanski
so that's a red dwarf preference
question ah
I'm partial to the first one I get why
they recast but like nostalgic Lee I
prefer original Kachinsky personally
well you see cardies the guys who are
you three if it comes out of course I
will
why wouldn't I the truth is unpopular
yes
frequently never saw a red dwarf it's
not for everybody but I love it
I just remember Phoebe gage selling that
telling that absurd Santa story okay
that's the first movie one of the great
moments till the second movie if she
starts to launch into another story like
that and Billy just kind of shoes her
off like no no not right now not right
now and then so she she winds up to do
that kind of thing again and these they
stop her and the second one I love it
first good chance he all day every day
second was too posh for me affair that
isn't that is a fair distinction between
the two
uh second Kochanski for me she sold me a
bastard
have you read the Percy Jackson books
new was it the constant fighting Saladin
that put you off the Sarah Jane
Adventures no I'd actually forgotten
that I'm sure it didn't help do you have
a preference of film or television
broadly speaking no not really
um I mean I kind of favor films slightly
because I like a complete experience
whereas television you're kind of on the
hook for especially these days with
everything being so realize you're on
the hook for years and you may or may
not end up happy with when when it's
done but I mean TV when it's done well
you can absolutely do stuff that film
can't so I enjoy both I am to get up in
five hours go to sleep my goodness
overdue Buffy the Vampire Slayer
probably not because I can't imagine
that there's anything that I'm gonna say
that passion of the nerd hasn't already
said and said better
so which Holly from Red Dwarf do you
prefer I do prefer original holiday both
Holly's were good
I do like original a little bit better
for further to drive in for experience
yes I do enjoy drive-ins um and there
actually is one in in Vermont so that's
nice but yeah I kind of prefer the
theater you buy the theory that they
fake fire James Gunn and wait until the
controversy was over to get him back um
having dug into it a bit I there's a
certain amount of credence that I give
to that but not completely like so
here's ah here's where I said on that
for how quietly they were able to bring
him back on board and how many people
would have had to clear it in the months
and how long like renegotiating separate
contracts and everything would have
taken um they probably were working on
getting him back almost immediately
after firing him I do not however I do
not believe that that initial firing was
in any way fake I think that was Disney
doing the standard corporate response to
that kind of controversy and severing
ties what I think may very well have
been the case was that upon review they
realized crap we shouldn't have done
that but rather than bring him back
while the heat was still on the whole
topic to to basically behind closed
doors negotiate to get him back again
because I mean if the whole thing was
planned from the beginning the firing
and everything he would not have signed
on to do Suicide Squad - which is gonna
do before Guardians 3 and also keep in
mind they had geared up pre-production
they had to shut it down they lost
significant money doing this so I think
that initial firing was legit um I think
probably almost immediately they started
working on getting him back though
there's a drive-in about 45 minutes to
an hour from me I go I don't know how
far it is from where I am but Liz and I
have gone to the drive-thru a few times
favorite historical character depiction
in Doctor Who mine has to be Vincent van
Gogh handles him deal with depression so
well I mean yeah I mean easily that one
what about Xena Warrior Princess I've
only seen a little bits of it only seen
a couple of episodes jumping off to put
momo-chan to bed remember your dwarf
Scout motto and good night chat let's
hit it in credit oh you shameless
self-promoter Jon I would take my hat
off to you if I was wearing it but I'm
not so goodnight and say hi to say hi
had occurred Ian the kid
I'll sleep when I'm dead yeah that's
what you think do you listen to any
other team Puma knife podcast I've been
meaning to check some of the other ones
out I haven't gotten to it though just
because like I'm a little reticent to
like I'm so behind on the podcast I
already listened to on most of them
improvised weapons is one of the only
ones I'm current on that I'm kind of
reticent to like load up more that I'm
just gonna fall behind on I triple dog
dare you to watch the first episode of
season 12 while drunk on its first
airing I can't do that cuz I'm only 13
no no I don't I don't think I will be
doing that to end the stream favorite
music and uh Meg with the drink
questions very nice
so yeah people people who are new here
that those questions get asked so often
that we've turned them everybody take a
drink questions and yes we'll wrap up
there cuz I actually do need to I need
to try and finish watching Good Omens
and maybe get a little editing done
maybe we'll see but everybody thanks for
tuning in thanks for the chat and I hope
everybody has a good week I hope mine
gets better I really hope that when I
get the call from the mechanic on my car
that it doesn't break my wallet
um legitimately really paranoid about
that but it'll be what it is so right
now thank you all hope you have a good
night thanks for tuning in remember
folks you are beautiful
you're valid you are loved you are the
counsel and I am very happy to have you